الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه عام 2020
شهدت فوزا غير متوقع المرشح الديمقراطيس
على نظيره الجمهوري دونالد ترامب في عده
ولايات عرفت بعضها سابقا بالولاء للحزب
الجمهوريته
لكن كانت درسا قاسيا قدمهم الناخب
الجمهوري لترامب
زعلان
[موسيقى]
حزب الجمهوري وباتت ارينا ساحه معركه في
الصراع الداخلي الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب كان في مواجهه جون ماكين السيناتور
الطويل الخدمه في ولايه ارينا مكين عرف
عنه انه من اشد
وبقي معارضا له حتى وفاته في اغسطس 2018
[موسيقى]
وفي احد خطابات ترامب عام 2019 زله لسان
للرئيس السابق كلفته كرسيه البيت الابيض
عام 2020 بعد اهانته السيناتور الرحل جم
ماكين الذي يعتبره جمهوريون في اريزونا
وطلع حرب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الان مقعد جون ماكين في مجلس الشيوخ عن
ولايه اريزونا مطروح في انتخابات التجديد
النصفيه لا يمكن التقاضي عن سيطره ترامب
على حزب الجمهوري في ولايه اريزونا التي
يخوض بلايك
قوي من الرئيس السابق انتخابات على مقعده
الا انه لا يعرف هل تصوت ولايه اريزونا
لمرشح جمهوريا مؤيدا لترامب ان تكرر
سيناريو انتخابات 2020
وتواصل انتقامها لمكان